federführend sind es ja hallo leute
hilft wieder eure mal wanne und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt darf ich mir von euch gewünscht
haben machen wir heute die pfannkuchen
torte von pettersson und findus und
dafür habe ich sogar das original rezept
gefunden und dafür brauchen wir zehn
eier 800 milliliter milch sechs
esslöffel zucker zwei teelöffel salz 500
gramm googles bio vollkommen verändert
milliliter mit allein wasser der
esslöffel fett und fett zum backen und
für die füllung die 100 milliliter sahne
marmelade und zwar selbst gemacht und
richtet zum garnieren und los geht's
eröffneten wir die eier in die
rührschüssel machen jetzt kommt
finanzminister in die hübsche sich jetzt
noch vier esslöffel jetzt kommt noch
sechs esslöffel zucker rein und seid
hier dafür sein
und das müssen wir jetzt alles zusammen
und jetzt gehen wir noch nach und nach
hinzu fertig jetzt kommt die restliche
milch dazu und zu guter letzt 200
milliliter wein wasser und nun alles gut
verrühren und jetzt werden die
fangruppen nacheinander gebraten während
die fatah prix müssen wir die sahne
steif schlagen und jetzt nicht jeden
pfannkuchen die marmelade und die sahne
auch vernünftig macht ihr noch eine
schippe drauf und dann mit dir alles mit
früchten garnieren
und die allerwichtigste frage ist jetzt
wie schmeckt
[Musik]
ich hoffe euch das video gefallen und
wenn ja dann hinterlassen einen daumen
nach oben und wenn ihr wissen wollt wer
meine absoluten lieblings youtuber sind
der sollte diese beiden kanäle aus
checken und hier könnt ihr noch mit
abonnieren aber definitiv solltet immer
da hingucken einfach so also das hat
nichts mit dem video zu tun
er hat einfach nur mal sagen dass dann